I was just saying that how thrilled I am
to be here with all of you and I know
Jane is - we've been looking forward to
this very much and how thrilled I am to
be doing this with Jane because I when I
was a little girl I used to look at Jane
and she was so glamorous and she seemed
to be doing such important things but I
was rather in or of her and we
rediscovered each other about 10 years
ago and became firm friends and I really
treasured that friendship and as Larry
told you she has powerful qualifications
because she had these two uncles who
both were in key positions at just after
the war and certainly you know my
grandfather was really lucky to have her
and I think that she had a lovely time
and what I want to do today is to sort
of ask Jane what it was like to be at 10
Downing Street and at Hyde Park gate
with my grandfather because I think that
she has she has a story to tell which
you know we have any number of
historians but she was there you put it
down your throat I think like that can
you hear now yeah um I want to say first
of all I'm so honored yeah with such
wonderful people all of whom we all have
the same interest and love of work the
greatest man who ever lived Winston
Churchill and
[Applause]
also but particularly Celia I'm so
indebted you not just for friendship but
for allowing me the opportunities to
talk about your wonderful grandfather
and I remember you say well when I was
first there in the whole way through the
six years with Churchill which was from
1949 to 55 days later he used to we used
to see Celia running in the garden you
were about six or seven years old and he
searched Hall used to call her my little
redheads and he loved and she they were
up and down the chart or also high
pocket and out in streets a we've known
each other a long time but as Celia said
our friendship has grown and maybe would
it be a good if I just said how I came
to work absolutely I think it'd be very
good my uncle Ram with whom I lived I
don't a secretary of course and the
Conservative Party's unit was in
opposition and Reb was busy forming the
next policy for the what would they were
certain would be another Conservative
government and he came back to where we
lived one evening and said to me I've
just been with Church with Winston and I
was in the office and they're crying out
for another secretary he was at that
point on the fourth wall of the history
of the Second World War there it and so
he said there's the head secretary said
we just can't cope with his import of
work he was a relentless worker and
round the clock and they said we need
someone young
strong to do the night work and wrap
said to me why don't you have a girl I
was 18 I was had a child of the wall but
we had listened to Churchill on his
radio broadcasts throughout the war and
he was an icon I mean they met to
imagine I'd never set eyes on which the
Churchill was impossible to think of and
so anyway I got into my best areas and
rang up hypergate and they said yes come
along for an interview you'll be
interviewed well mr. Churchill gosh I
got frightened and I went along to Hyde
Park it and it was after lunch and there
were two houses at I pocket with an
intersecting passage and the family
lived in one house and offices and out
the house and as I stood at one end of
the passage between the two houses
suddenly I see Winston Churchill
standing the other end of the passage
he's dressed for the House of Commons in
his strike suits and waistcoat and he
walks towards me smiling holds out his
hand shakes my hand walks throughout me
shakes my head and walks away
and gestured it the head secretary said
well that's all right when can you begin
sir
I mean think of the disgrace of that
sort of interview nowadays and so I said
month and I was there on Monday and I
was there for six years and there were
two and I think there were two elections
of course 1958 the Labour Party returned
with the majority of six seats
nobody can cover with six see-through
sorting and Churchill who was at that
point and for the rest of his life
obsessed with his feeling that it was
for him to bring peace to the Western
democracy again and bring peace with the
Soviet Communism of Russia and he'd
known Stalin talked to him in the war
got on with him so it has been Eve and
so that this was his obsession and so he
was determined to be a peacetime Prime
Minister and you know people think of
Churchill as the Great Wall Mountain
monger he was a peacemaker
he fought war was for the sake of peace
and so that he he then knew he would be
proud minister he was too convinced he
would and 18 months later
indeed the Conservatives won another
election and with the majority of 26 not
very many and he was on his way to
Buckingham Palace to see the Queen to
shake hands and to move to Downing
Street and he took traverse Elizabeth
deliver myself with him - don't
and we worked the Churchill's had the
trap the Prime Minister's it's all
different now but the Prime Minister's
flap was at the top of the house
Churchill had the big big bedroom
overlooking Horse Guards Parade where he
would work as we all know he worked in
bed it's great bed and he's brocade
dressing people would come to see him
there in the mornings cabinet ministers
anybody would be shown up to his bedroom
and he would have the cat on one end of
the bed and the dog poodle Rufus on the
other end and a Buttrick of like around
and he would get on with his work and so
it went on in the afternoons try so each
leadership question tonight in the
hearts of competence and there was not
the aggravating first question that we
all know about now this was a time of he
loved question time and it was a time
for wit and getting on with everybody I
think how differently well it might be
opened up and said we'd work in his room
in the House of Commons and he'd have an
ass nap or something during the day and
then this was Mundt it's a thirsty and
then he goes to job for and when he was
Prime Minister of course he was expected
to get checkers but he made an arranger
because as you all know but Celia is
better than anyone he loved Java more
than anywhere in the world he was at
peace at total and he knew it with that
and he could get on with his work he was
still his first two years he was still
finishing the world map were us and
after dinner I chopped war if the dining
room in those days you've been chocolate
yeah I know the dining room is in the
basement and those days it was just
along the passage from me his study and
certainly he would always remember I
would have a table in the corner with a
typewriter great on it he would come in
after the other
10:30 in his satin suit and he'd be
murmuring to himself murmuring the words
he was going to dictate and he'd walk up
and down that study and dictate to me on
the typewriter and instead you see you
had to have carbon copies and everything
you better do make copies so I'd get
that ready and then Thursday it's also
there was a radiogram the corner and he
would have playing music or songs or
bought songs and I had to know as I
turned and he spoke and he'd be deep
into his speaking but I was scared up
turn it for the six records he put on so
that was worrying and I said oh I used
to put on it's number six cuz it was
weren't my favorites a record and went
and she was an air-dropped daughter but
her bathing suit never got wet
and so I knew when we got to that I jump
up turn them out but back to about Joe
clutter and there'd be a gap but he knew
he'd never said to me why is this gap
he'd fit it in with his handwriting and
then the proofs would go every day by
the end of the day there's this
wonderful word about two o'clock in the
morning soup and he would drink both
Conte something and at that matter it
was the end of the working day he'd go
to bed and I would put the proofs but at
the front door when I come to think of
it to think the front door was left and
the driver would arrive septic lock the
next morning take it to the station and
the proofs would be back that evening
and he would settle down and correct
them and said that was the way in
history got written and later when he
was bright minister he'd be dictating
speeches to the powers so that was how I
came to work day and night and it's so
true that we all loved him there was
nothing that he asked of us there was
too much night all day and of course he
never asked more that he was giving
himself and we were aware of that and we
never resented it for a moment and we
all got on with each other and it was a
very happy absolute working arrangement
but Jane I sorry when when I was growing
up he the one thing he always used to
say to us we must never let the Sun go
down on our quarrels yeah and we always
say sorry and make up and I think he was
a bit like that wasn't EVF upset someone
he always said sorry well the thing was
patience was a virtue
which he had no acquaintances at all and
so there would be the most terrible
upsets and shouting and sometimes even
threaten dependent pen across the room
or something and I used to just get out
of the room but and he never apologized
and I am so pleased that he didn't
apologize that would have spoilt
everything because it was nearly always
because I'd forgotten something and but
as Celia said so true by the end of the
day there'd be a gesture it's usually a
smile and that smile you've got
attention and but it's it would say
magical and that would be good enough
and said that was it
you're quite right did something didn't
go down without the smile but did you do
you remember what happened when King
George the sixth ride yes
now I'd love to have my back I'm so sore
just something I know I know
thank you lady with many bags thank you
because I had a bag lady Begley thank
you but George is at six died sorry can
hear George or two six died in February
1952 and the young Queen was in Kenya
may be called genius I lived
of course it's Kenya now and the young
Queen came back from Kenya with Prince
Phillip and Churchill was too broad
God's to the nation at night and he had
not nearly finished his dictation
because he was so meticulous
with his work with it was an ATO
broadcasts whatever it was he so much
time would be spent getting it right and
correcting it and he said I haven't
finished yet
and so I need to take you in the car to
what was then and an airport where the
Queen came back and I remember that he
dictated their way and the other thing
that maybe you know Churchill was a
romantic he was so wonderfully
kind-hearted
he loved the Queen and who he already
knew and he was determined to make it
good and so he as he we drove in color
and it happened quite often he wept and
I have never know who went to
beautifully it's Winston Churchill and
even ever so often when when I cried for
instance it's it's a horror story but he
tears just poured out his face and he'd
be quite still sometimes and in the car
as he went he wept I've written ditz
down because I remember it said well for
that dictation in the carpets to London
Airport and he I think this is just so
beautiful he said dictated during its
last month's the king walked with death
as if death were a companion and
acquaintance whom he recognized and did
not fear
in the end death came as a friend and
after a happy day of sports and sunshine
and after saying goodbye to those who
loved him he fell asleep as every man
and woman who strives to fear God and
nothing else in the world may hope to do
and he dictated those words in God of
weeping we got along we got to London
Airport and the plane had grown up and
there's a wonderful photo of which time
to show you know of Churchill with his
cabinet he's at the top of the road but
it's the back view by the steps of the
airplane and the cabinet the broad
figure of Winston Churchill Brightman
the new prime minister next in the
elegance of Antony Eden and then so on
that whole cabinet and as I looked out
at the window I saw Antony Ethan's
private secretary who was caught even
into shock wonderful man and evening
said to me this is history we've got to
watch it and we got I got active it's
nope behind the wheels of a plate and
just nearby and I remember seeing this
beautiful young woman girl she was 25
years old
slim the Queen standing at the top of
the aeroplane steps ready to greet her
cabinet and he she greeted the cabinet
and we drove back to London the
broadcast was absolutely wonderful and
that was a February 1952
and then of course there was the
coronation next yeah in May 8 1953 it
was the complication and Churchill
Anthony Eden back then was desperately
ill and was in states having medical
treatment so Churchill might he's
decided he'd take over the Foreign
Office and there was one point he said I
think I got working the front part in
office the Foreign Office didn't really
like the idea so he stated number 10 and
there was the coordination and after the
coronation he was tired he was so so
tired with all the kind of little vigil
and he had this stroke was an
extraordinary thing wasn't it when they
managed to pull the wool over everyone's
eyes I know I mean that couldn't
possibly happen now but it was decided
with a very select few people of course
Jacque over rode to the Queen
immediately and he said the monarch was
informed and also this is what was saved
his best friends who were the newspaper
proprietors they were important and he
said I have not finished the job I was
given to do to bring peace to the world
and I'm going to keep quiet about this
is to be kept quiet and Anthony Eden
knew rare but you the cabinet didn't
know and the chairman of the cabinet
knew the Secretary of the cabinet
Norman broke me other words nobody knew
the family knew you knew well we knew
there was a lot of drama and upset going
on in every
tenterhooks so we did I did no I do
remember being people talking in hushed
whispers and thinking something dreadful
was happening well it was dreadful
because he was a very serious and he was
a very very strict but he was coherent
and he had his mind was completely clear
the stroke happened on a Tuesday night
he went to the cabinet the next morning
on Wednesday and my uncle Reb doped me
nobody noticed that anything was wrong
except they thought the Prime Minister
is very quiet today and then he went
straight up to his Rahman he said I'm
caged
charcoal which was where he would be
happy all the doctors had come to see it
they said this is very serious and
whether he recovers or not is in the
balance he went down to charcoal at that
Thurston and I went to the police car
but happened and set up the office
because we had to and joke of it was
very much that we had to pretend that
nothing was happening
didn't do everyone say he was exhausted
or some wasn't that the story the
medical need the doctors issued a
statement saying that he needed a
month's rest it had been too strenuous
the coronation festivities so that I was
there at the whole time he was there at
chakra for two and a half months to
begin with his speech became totally
slurred and his left arm he couldn't
move his left arm he was in his bedroom
I didn't know chart what I don't think
they opened up the bedroom you don't go
into the bedroom it's just me on the
stud
and say he was in his bedroom and but he
was never once during that whole period
did I ever hear him complaining or
grandpa or feel sorry for himself and he
was seriously ill but he had nurses and
they would put him in a wheelchair and
wheel him to the dining room for me it
was where the family gather and he would
come back to his bed and Joe Colvin and
I set up a reading table and he um he
would read classical books he loved
Trollope and I remember he couldn't turn
the Patriots you see so I remember
sitting sometimes for an hour and a half
just looking at this wonderful it's this
wonderful person and when he got to the
end of the pair each he'd blink and I
turned the page and Joxer thisit's with
me and said that he was very good in a
way at peace with that and the black box
is the government motor bicycles came
down out with all the government papers
and they piled up and they were dealt
with by Joe Cocker and by his son-in-law
Christopher sales and nobody guessed I
mean that is what is so scandalous isn't
it really I always think if that
happened now I couldn't do it you see in
those days it's a different world to
everybody in this were in its room there
was no such thing as a mobile phone
there was nothing except conversation
and there were telephones
so that was how the stroke regrets and
he got better the whole time and by
August the stroke could happen 23rd June
by August he was able to go to back to
the cabinet brought back to number 10
and he took a cabinet meeting and still
nobody guessed and then he went see the
Queen about Martin and just for 24 hours
and then he went down to the South of
France - no beaver Brooks hearts there
and she thought but you never seen Cap'n
Tina
and he stayed there for two he but then
he had another girl which was the
Conservative Party conference annual
conference which was to take place in
October in Margate and he was determined
to prove himself so his party didn't he
say that if I can do that then I can
stay on yes exactly see ya
he said if I could exactly those words
and so ty there would be copy after copy
after copy he was writing this wonderful
speech to the Conservative Party
conference and in fact I'm getting to
the end of my pieces and I watch because
they're not after Margate and it was a
huge success the whole room rose to
their feet and I was sitting in the
audience correcting the proof because
that's what they are cuts it so
wonderful because all these proofs were
corrected by the hair as he spoke by one
of us and it was the old Churchill it
was the orator it was the width it was
the purpose
and he then had proved himself there and
he at that point after that he stayed on
for a little bit and then he went back
to talk to or read on there he was
traveling and that was where Celia
traveled with him the whole time on Asus
is he Orton he was writing his history
of the english-speaking peoples so he
never stopped almost till the day he
died I wasn't a few months but he went
on and what he really liked doing was
painting I mean he's the greatest sort
of sorry and if there's the wonderful
painting but he could do he loved that
he really loved that but it was I mean I
was very lucky because I was just an
available grandchild of a suitable age
to travel with him at the air in the end
of his life but we did have this
incredible cruise on the Christina where
we went from Monte Carlo to Istanbul and
back on a very sort of dramatic cruise
because the other guests were mayor
Callas and her husband and so he had
this incredible thing and I was not yet
sixteen and so I was watching this
extraordinary thing going on in front of
my eyes this romance between Onassis and
Callas in front of her husband and his
wife and it was a sort of thing I could
only read about in the magazines that
were considered unsuitable so I would
say I was absolutely transfixed all the
grown-ups were absolutely horrified but
I was in chantix I was having a lot of
fun and it was very entertaining not to
mention there was a very glamorous tutor
for the Onassis children who I really
fancied but by the end of the cruise the
marriage was over but for the time of
the cruise it had everything had to go
on as normal and it was quite a quite
extraordinary but my grandfather would
sit there and Calais we all hated Calais
and she used to try and feed him ice
cream from her with her spoon and he was
perfectly capable of feeding himself
and she was horrified one day when we
arrived at Epidaurus at this incredible
amphitheater which was piled high with
flowers and they were in the shape of a
V so this was really her natural habitat
she'd sung there many times she turned
to my mother and said Oh Diane and what
beautiful flowers
what kind people but why do you think
they're in the shape of a V and the look
on her face when my mother said because
Maria they're not for you they're for
Papa but I did some wonderful life spent
a lot of time with in the South of
France was also really lovely and on one
occasion we had this drama when he broke
his hip and he fell in his room and he
broke his hip and it was just him and
Anthony Montagu Brown and me there and
Sir Anthony and I walked to the hospital
and he said you know Celia he's not
going to make it so we got into his room
and seemed as all the medical staff of
the hospital congregated there on a
thorough sightseeing tour so he looked
around the room he looked incredibly
frail but he gathered the strength of
dismissed that all the medical staff and
turned to Antony and said I want to die
in England you'll make this happen
weren't you and he didn't get an
immediate reply because I knew because I
knew what Anthony had just said to me
before and so he said promise me so
Anthony said yes I promise but as we
walked back to the hotel he said that's
the promise I'm not going to be able to
keep but he made a call to Harold
Macmillan who was the prime minister at
the time and an RAF vc10 ambulance plane
was ordered to come and collect him and
take him home so the next morning he was
loaded onto a stretcher bed which was
wheeled onto the the lift you call it
the elevator that would take the food up
to the airplane and he was taken up on
that and then placed in a stripped-down
body of the aircraft
and they gave me a chair and I sat next
to him and all I could do was hope and
pray that he would make it we got to
Heathrow and he again was put out on the
elevator and as he was lowered slowly
down to the ground he spotted a little
group of airport workers who were
absolutely ashen-faced the color of
these tablecloths and he seemed to get a
burst of adrenaline he looked he smiled
he gave them a V sign they all clapped
and we knew he was going to be all right
he was all right never quite the same
again castelia it's the Winston was
there a Winston there's last days that
was extraordinary but the you told us
about the cat on the bed yes and I
remember well I used to love going to
see him having his breakfast in bed in
the mall and there would be the cat
snuggled up the newspapers strewn over
the bed and very likely a secretary
taking dictation might have been you
might meet me and Rufus would run around
and the budgerigar would swoop in to get
a tip bit or two and when after he'd had
his stroke he was took he was
unconscious really for ten days and
every day I would go to see him and the
cat would be snuggled up beside him and
it seemed 10 long days that cat never
seemed to move but it was an
extraordinary faithful cat I think but
it was a terrible time it was absolutely
extraordinary extraordinary the crowds
gathered outside and then eventually
they were moved up to the end of the
street but it was it was extraordinary
going to see him and the extraordinary
thing was that a few years before he
told I think it was jock was it yes that
he was going to die on the anniversary
of yes are the Lord Randolph
so you know we knew this but we couldn't
really take it seriously but I believe
that people they used to ring from
Buckingham Palace and Antony Montagu
Brown would answer the phone they said
well when it's what's happening how is
he you know the sort of way people ask
how is someone meaning you know because
they had a lot of things to be put into
actions everyone knew he was going to
die and C said oh he won't die yet he
won't die for he's going to die on the
24th of January and they must have I
must have been [ __ ] in Paris they
must have thought he was quite mad
anyway on the morning of the 24th of
January in 1965 we gathered around his
bed and 70 years to the day and probably
to the minute because no one recorded
the minute when Lord Randolph died his
son slipped imperceptibly a way to meet
his maker it was an extraordinary
extraordinary thing and for me I'd
always been rather scared of dying but
it removed all fear of death from me
because it was just such a peaceful
thing so I've got that thank you for -
and then the funeral was something yes
we were both there yeah we were there as
the family but it was it was quite
extraordinary it was an extraordinary
day and it was such a day that I didn't
you know you were we were all going
through it
as they we were acting in a play and my
sister and I were in the carriage behind
my grandmother and my two R's and we'd
had an incident a few years before when
we were much younger when we'd been
taken to a window under Big Ben when
Queen Mary the Queen's grandmother had
died and she was taken to Lyons state
and we were placed in a window and
obviously our parents thought we were
terribly well behaved so they left us
there without any instructions what to
do next morning it was a photograph in
the newspaper of two little girls
roaring with laughter over the top of
the coffin
so when we got into our carriage we said
we'd better not talk to each other
because it's difficult just talk to
someone who you're fond of without
showing some animation so we held each
other's hands and squeeze them
occasionally but we didn't say a word
for the whole journey but it wasn't
extraordin extraordinary day but i only
when i got home in the evening and
turned on the television i got the holy
import of the day from a different angle
because you could see what was happening
because we couldn't see what was
happening here because we were in it
Jane thanks so much you've done it's
lovely in doing this with you it's so
much fun so much fun and thank you very
very much and thank you Larry for
producing all those wonderful companion
volumes of all that yes my grandfather's
name
[Applause]
you